[Musique]
mais je pensais te voir à l'extérieur
mais sans ton copain c'est possible
mais non faut pas lui demander parce que
après il va me casser la gueule
je m'appelle James cet été je suis resté
à Paris pour me préparer pour une
compétition de musculation et ça m'en
fait pas de sortir c'est bien les femmes
bonjour
de femmes maintenant entre draguer et
conclure ces deux choses différentes je
travaillais beaucoup de faire j'essaye
de draguer au moins 5 6 10 par jour
c'est draguer c'est parler faire
connaissance maintenant si ça marche pas
on recommence on recommence jusqu'à ce
que ça marche
j'adore ça c'est je peux pas m'en passer
de voir je peux pas dès qu'il y a une
belle femme qui passe que je peux pas me
tourner la tête c'est c'est plus fort
que moi c'est en fait c'est quelqu'un
d'autre qui est à l'intérieur de moi qui
va vers elle et je le sais et c'est
super
j'ai pas pu m'empêcher de tu peux
m'asseoir à côté de vous
passer à Paris
vous êtes parisien vous êtes français
vous êtes à Paris en vacances ou quoi
ça va
qu'est-ce que je voulais dire vous je
sais pas vous vous êtes ensemble je sais
pas parce que tellement je t'ai trouvé
jolie je pensais que en plus il fait
beau tout le monde est
séduisante mais je pensais te voir à
l'extérieur mais sans ton copain c'est
possible
mais non faut pas lui demander parce que
après il va me casser la gueule
faut pas que il comprend pas français
[Musique]
j'aime bien collectionner les femmes
mais ce que je me suis fixé dans la tête
enfin c'était un rêve mais j'aimerais
connaître toutes les femmes du monde
donc d'abord on commence par Paris
ensuite la France et après le monde
entier mais je pense que c'est un peu
dur mais c'est un challenge pour moi
aujourd'hui
je suis heureux parce que j'ai trouvé
deux pour le prix
c'est une façon de parler en français je
peux me mettre au milieu des deux comme
ça
vous avez une énergie phénoménale alors
toutes les femmes du monde entier 6 10
par jour à draguer c'est est-ce que
c'est l'été qui vous met dans cet état
là de délire complet
[Musique]
l'été bon c'est vrai que les femmes sont
habillées différemment elles se mettent
plus en valeur leur corps donc forcément
mais vicieux ils vont sur leur forme et
bon ça crée tout de suite
des sensations des
choses en moi justement quand on veut
devenir comme vous à un sportif
professionnel est-ce qu'on a le temps et
est-ce qu'on a l'énergie à dépenser à
draguer parce qu'il faut de l'énergie
quand même c'est bon c'est je prépare la
compétition en fait d'ici une semaine
donc je pars complètement à Nice
m'entraîner je quitte Paris parce que
c'est je peux plus il y a tellement de
femmes il y a tellement de choses qui
qui m'empêche de d'être sérieux dans mon
sport et j'ai envie de réussir de le
préparer comme il faut et de gagner ce
que vous avez le ou que les muscles
plaisent aux femmes toutes les femmes
parce que il y en a qui préfèrent les
mains c'est grand bon je suis pas très
grand et en plus je suis musclé plus je
parie petit donc
oui mais bon mon sport il passe avant
tout quand même donc je préfère mon
sport avant mais bon c'est avant la
drague avant la drague vous avez 22 ans
c'est pratiquement toute votre journée à
vous entraîner à faire de la musculation
montrez-moi là sont des vrais c'est de
la gonflette ah oui non c'est dur
à les faire je travaille très lourd avec
des charges assez lourdes donc on peut
pas assez un peu ça à la gonflette
erotica ça Amsterdam l'année dernière
cette année
j'étais danseur je faisais des
spectacles par rapport à mon corps
alors Maëva est-ce que pour vous c'est
vraiment
j'avais presque envie de dire un objet
érotique un homme érotique
personnellement parce que vous aimez ces
muscles j'aime le corps quand il est
bien dessiné donc un muscle bien dessiné
est attrayant maintenant personnellement
non mais bon c'est chacun c'est c'est
est-ce que ça est-ce que ça vous vexe
quand elle vous dit ça non c'est normal
elle est trop belle pour moi
je sais que bon je peux pas plaire à
toutes les femmes donc une femme comme
ça j'essaie même pas de la draguer parce
que je me dis j'ai aucune chance
parce que je reste j'admire sans la
beauté de son physique quand même c'est
agréable à voir
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]